hey YouTube how's it going my name is
Matt you're watching probably something
on my channel code tech and tutorials
where I post things about code and
taking random tutorials things I've
learned so hey hello if you're new here
you can subscribe if you like here and
you know all the usual stuff appreciate
having new viewers all the time
this video is about my game engine which
I have titled the game engine I've
titled ancient Archer it was it sort of
started out as a game and it has just
sort of changed or shifted and yeah I'm
gonna start vlogging about it and this
is kind of a new phase here I took about
a month off to deal with some personal
issues my father passed away and I'm
trying to get back on the ball here
reality has set in and you know it's
it's been a tough time it was a good man
I'm not gonna say too much about it on
here yeah but I'll put something on the
screen so now this is kind of where my
engine is I can I can do primitive base
stuff blocks circles circles spheres and
right now I've just got a camera with no
collision turned on but we were working
on some collision and physics as well
and by we I do mean mainly me but I did
have a friend that was helping out for a
while thank you Eric for your help out
when you were helping out I hope you can
rejoin at some point but I believe he is
busy with a real job at the moment
however I'm gonna keep continuing this
project and we're basically gonna we're
basically gonna take it as far as we can
go now so yeah this is this is the thing
and I'm going down into the world I know
it's weird but with collision off you
can just fly through objects so that's
the way it is everything's done in
OpenGL and basically what I'm gonna do
here is uh
this is this is the code and all the
files and I've got everything up on
github
it is currently private though that can
change that can change details to come
but yeah there's quite a bit going on
here at the moment it's actually getting
to be a bit of a mess with the different
shaders and code and ideas and and
things going on and I go here to manage
branches you'll see there's some
additional work build one and build two
are kind of the classic first iterations
oops I just switched to it I don't think
I actually went in there right now but
these are kind of the classic first real
builds of this engine where I was kind
of showing it off to my friends and then
we went through and and worked on just a
bunch of side games to see how they
would turn out basically spend like a
week on them and none of them were are
really too worth showing I don't think
they're very very primitive and not
really you know not a clear end clear
beginning they're more like just some
systems working so there are some tests
and stuff like that with some
interaction but not enough to be like a
real fun game and you know after taking
this month off I'm kind of reflecting a
lot and having a lot of just time to
think about how I was doing things on
this engine
I think I'm just gonna start from
scratch and I do want to vlog it and and
just really go over everything but you
know vlogging and editing it takes a lot
of time and energy and if I'm gonna do
it consistently I'm gonna need some help
so I did put up a patreon link and by
scription and if you want to see vlogs
on on basically this engine you can go
there and and sign up and we'll we'll do
this together
yeah it's a it's gonna be a lot I have a
lot of big plants as this engine is
right now everything is just rendering
with OpenGL using geo fw3 for the input
system I'm using mostly GLM for most of
the math functions and and I'm basically
just setting up systems for loading
things rendering things colliding
physics and I have a few games in mind
that I would like to try to make and I I
tend towards are either dungeon crawl or
open-world so I intend to support all
those capabilities in one way or another
as that's what I'll want the whatever
game I'm building to have so it's just
building a lot of features and making
them easy for other developers mostly me
I guess but other developers - - to work
with
we're just going to delete all our
source code as scary as it sounds it's
all I'm github so I can go grab what I
need back but I'm gonna restructure this
entire thing it is just gotten to be a
bit of a mess and I want to reset I
think packages are going is going to be
gone game is going to be gone it's
basically just going to have engine and
probably tests yeah so
I think that those will all stay under
CPP though that makes sense to me
so we're just gonna delete everything in
engine everything in game and everything
in packages
and it's gone that's 88 files oh okay
we're also gonna get rid of resources we
are keeping our library and includes
because those are not really going to
change right now and that's an easy
thing to change when when we're ready to
do it
these debug this is from the build this
isn't something I have debug and release
and x64 this is from Visual Studio so
those aren't even part of my source code
it's part of just the builds you might
already know that but in case you don't
there's a bunch of dll's for runtimes
those are all gonna stay the same and
I'll probably update my libraries before
continuing it's just part of the build
and I'll probably update the design and
readme as well so we'll see I'll see
where we get basically so if you want to
see this next vlog of how this is going
and we're starting please consider
visiting the patreon and in signing up
and the
much how it's got to be because the
other option is I gotta start working
somewhere pretty much full-time and
probably won't be able to spend much
time editing I think I'll still work on
this but as far as producing videos
about it and explaining it that yeah
that won't happen too often I might do
it on a whim every once in a while but I
definitely won't go into in depth you
know steps or really what I'm doing
it'll just be kind of like a here's
where here's what it looks like right
now type thing so and if there's really
enough interest we'll make the source
code available I'm not sure at what
level that will happen but at least the
parts that are explained in videos will
will be there all right well thank you
for watching I hope you guys all have a
great day great everything you know
you're here you have my vote of you're
cool well see you guys later
you